so mr. president mr. prime minister
honorable members on behalf of President
Juncker who is preparing the State of
the Union address that will be delivered
tomorrow to this house I'm delighted to
take part in this future of Europe
debate in the presence of Prime Minister
Alexis tsipras I had the opportunity to
work closely with Prime Minister tsipras
over the last few years most recently we
had a very good exchange on Greece and
the future of Europe when I visited when
I visit Athens in June before I turned
to our debate let me first express our
deep sympathy and solidarity to those
affected by the terrible forest fires
the Commission stands at your side and
we must make sure such tragedy will
never repeat Greece its people and Greek
civilization have shaped Europe and its
underlying values one can safely say
that the Greeks invented democracy and
above all they knew how to depend it how
to defend it when it was under threat
this allowed their country to join the
European Union under it during a
terrible dictatorship thus proving that
the future belongs to those who have a
courage not to succumb to this nation
the determination to face up to
difficulties and take their fate into
their own hands yes the future belongs
to those who choose to be architects of
history Greece is not only of historic
importance to Europe but it's also
important to the future of Europe it is
impossible to imagine the future of
Europe without Greece's contribution I'm
thinking in particular of its vital role
in the stability of the Western Balkans
the region was a turbulent history which
needs firm reassurance about the
prospect of EU membership in order to
avoid a repetition of the tragedies we
witnessed in the 1990s and I would like
to unsay ghin to pay tribute to the
courage and leadership of the Prime
Minister tsipras and zyo who have acted
in a spirit of openness and compromise
in order to break a longstanding
deadlock that serves the interests of
the neither country
they have set an example for the whole
region and the wider world I'm also
thinking of the future of our economic
and monetary union and the harsh lessons
which together we had to learn from the
crisis in the last 10 years that hit
Greece so hard although others took a
different view the Commission who has
always believed that Greece has its
rightful place in the euro area I'd like
to pay tribute to the unprecedented
efforts made by the Greek people to
maintain Greeks rightful place at the
heart of the European Union this summer
Greece has turned a new page it has
brought a stability program to the
successful clause it has put it public
finances in order and even exceeded its
budgetary targets its economy is on the
rise this year and next it's set to grow
by 2 percent unemployment has already
fall short ly also it's still
unacceptably high over 100,000 new jobs
have been created since the stability
programme began the credit assist
attunement is shared between the Greeks
and their European partners it is a
product of Europe's received for success
which combines solidarity with
responsibility solidarity
shown by European partners has been
unprecedented both in terms of the
financial assistance and in terms of
support for reforms the people of Greece
have been strong in taking the
responsibility their efforts and
sacrifices how laid the basis for this
sustainable upturn these are solid
foundations on which can Greece on which
Greece can now build yet there are still
economic challenges to overcome the best
investment Greece can now make is to
build confidence in its economy that
requires staying the course of
responsible fiscal policies and reforms
this is a way to ensure a long-lasting
economic growth and a constant
improvement of living conditions for the
Greek people in such a case I do not
exclude that the Greek economy will
surprise us on the upside when I see the
courage and
determination which great people have
already shown I am confident that they
will succeed and Greece can continue to
rely on the Solidarity from its European
partners in our union responsibility and
solidarity go hand in hand we proved as
much when we drew lessons from the
crisis and made our current common
currency more crisis resistant in order
to arm ourselves better to face future
challenges we must take the necessary
steps to complete the economic and
monetary union the Commission's roadmap
is clear its agenda is well known this
is an urgent priority for the autumn we
are finally making progress to complete
our banking union and I trust we can
swiftly move towards a real capital
markets union the example of Greece
shows that we can overcome problems when
we join forces the euro area has emerged
from the crisis United and stronger
because we choose common European
solutions dear colleagues as we look to
the future of Europe we must apply the
spirit of finding common solutions to
common challenges right across the board
this is what being a part of the union
means working together to address the
issues affecting a sole managing
migration is one such common European
challenge it's not a responsibility of
only one member state or another this is
why we stood side-by-side with Greece
when it mattered the most thanks to the
eu-turkey statement arrivals are now
down by 97% in the eastern Mediterranean
we back that up with the financial means
to match to match with Greece receiving
a total of 1.6 billion euros of EU funds
to address migration challenges and we
set up a European border and coast guard
to make our borders more secure we now
have over 1600 officers across Europe
including 662 officers in Greece at the
bird s border Swiss turkey Albania and
the former Yugoslavian Cydonia the
decisive action taken by the European
Union has
but we can and must do more together
it's time that Member States agreed on
the long-term solution covering all
elements of migration to help us balance
solidarity and responsibility there
would be no stronger and more tangible
proof to Europeans that the Union will
deliver on its promises and stay United
on the things that matter the most and I
believe that to do this we should look
at the teachings of one of the Europe's
greatest minds Sauron Greece's greatest
minds Aristotle he taught that virtue is
the middle between extremes that
understanding and compassion are central
to the way a society works and that we
are above all else all about also social
beings in our long and tragic history we
see the damage wrought when we lose
sight of this humanism so the lesson for
our future is simple we must never lose
sight of what binds us together the
values that we share the living together
in a society that we hold dear and the
compassion and solidarity that we show
each other
this is what our union is built on and
that's what our future must be built on
thank you
[Applause]